[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con desde la
toma de kabul hace poco más de una
semana la comunidad internacional ha
intentado encontrar la forma de paliar
la crisis en afganistán que volvió a
estar bajo control del talibán en medio
de la preocupación el primer ministro
británico boris johnson convocó a una
reunión virtual de los líderes del g-7
para este martes para conversar de este
tema nos acompaña andrés servín doctor
en ciencias políticas analista
internacional y presidente de la
coordinadora regional de investigaciones
económicas y sociales bienvenido señor
service y reino unido- ha dicho que
presionará para una extensión de la
fecha final del retiro de tropas una
posibilidad de la cual el presidente joe
biden también mostró cierta flexibilidad
cree usted que ese podría ser un tema de
consenso en esta reunión del g7
en principio sí porque el drama que está
viviendo en este momento afganistán en
términos de la presión ejercida por los
talibanes una vez que ocuparon kabul
sobre una gran proporción de la
población hace necesario algún tipo de
salida frente a esta crisis que esa toma
características de crisis humanitarias
por parte de los países occidentales lo
curioso es que mientras que el g7 se va
a reunir en el transcurso de esta semana
ya la semana pasada la organización de
cooperación de shanghai en donde
participan rusia y china- muy
activamente porque fueron las creadoras
se ha reunido en tayikistán y ha
empezado a tomar algún tipo de medidas
justamente para prevenir una dispersión
de los refugiados por toda la región y
además fundamentalmente para ver cómo
enfrentan la posibilidad de que
afganistán se convierta en un foco que
genere una amenaza terrorista para los
países de horacio yo creo que en esto es
muy importante entender que no solamente
en la visión occidental sobre lo que
está pasado lo que probablemente es una
gran catástrofe geopolítica
que se está desarrollando en afganistán
sino también ver cuál es la posición de
los países del ámbito duro asiático más
que nada porque con la retirada de eeuu
y de la otan de afganistán y afganistán
va a entrar probablemente en la órbita
de estos países ya que es también
miembro observador de la organización de
cooperación de shanghai mire sin embargo
entre es el talibán dijo este mismo
lunes que un evento a la extensión de la
fecha de retiro es una línea roja que
traería consecuencias de qué tipo de
consecuencias estamos hablando y esto
hará aún más inestable la situación a
inicios de septiembre
probablemente sí porque las
posibilidades de negociación de mantener
los canales de negociación contra rival
a pesar de que retóricamente dicen que
si están dispuestos a mantenerlos se
complejizan además por la conformación
del nuevo gobierno talibán en kabul
entre otras cosas porque hay toda una
serie de tensiones entre distintas
facciones y quienes van a imponerse
dentro de ese nuevo gobierno y además
hay en discusión hasta qué punto están
dispuestos a entablar negociaciones de
conversaciones con sectores adversos al
talibán en afganistán entre otros y
aquellos sectores que eran del gobierno
anterior y que están
organizando una resistencia armada
frente a los talibanes
pues andrés yo le agradezco mucho por la
información y el análisis y tener en
cuenta que de todas maneras a la
principal preocupación en este momento
sigue siendo la evacuación de miles y
miles de personas desde el aeropuerto de
kabul y reino unido- como lo hizo
también alemania en su momento ha
admitido que no podrá continuar con esta
labor una vez que eeuu se retire así que
veremos cómo avanza en france 24 hacemos
cubrimiento constante de la situación de
afganistán y los invitamos a ustedes a
seguir con toda nuestra programación en
france 24 y en france 24 punto com
[Música]